Muhammad hijab and Dr William Lane Craig
on is the Trinity
coherent in this video Dr William Lane
Craig and Muhammad hijab discuss their
respective views on the coherence of the
Trinity this is a very unique
opportunity to hear from two well-known
thinkers as they unpack one of
Christianity's most intricate and
debated doctrines let me go ahead and
pull them up on the scene here so you
guys can see both of my guests Dr
William Lan Craig is a Christian and a
distinguished philosopher and theologian
serving as a research professor at
talbat School of Theology and professor
at Houston Christian University renowned
for his work on cosmological and moral
Arguments for God's existence Dr Craig
has engaged in numerous discussions with
both atheist and theist he's also
participated in Interfaith dialogues
with Muslim Scholars uh like shabir Ali
and now with Muhammad hijab he's also
participated oh sorry I've already uh
read that part his uh contri tion to one
God three persons for viws a theological
and philosophical dialogue edited by
Chad Macintosh highlights his expertise
on the Trinity making him an ideal for
uh ideal guest for today's conversation
joining him is Muhammad hijab a Muslim
philosopher of religion and co-founder
of sapiens Institute Muhammad's
discussions representing the Islamic
Viewpoint philosophically politically
and theologically are among the most
viewed globally with 1.2 million YouTube
subscribers he is a significant voice
online providing Islamic perspective on
a wide range of topics additionally
Muhammad is pursuing his PhD at the
University of Birmingham where he
continues to deepen his studies in
philosophy and theology we're talking
about the coherence of the Trinity is
the concept of one God in three persons
logically coherent or does it present
fundamental philosophical challenges so
to begin each participant will share
their positions on the Trinity they will
each have three minutes for opening
remarks followed by a discussion period
with two minute timed responses as
moderator I will take a very active role
in ensuring equal speaking time for both
participants so let's begin with Dr
Craig's opening remarks yeah thank you
Cameron um it's a delight to have the
invitation to be part of today's
Dialogue on the Trinity with Mr hijab as
you know uh ever since doing my doctoral
work in philosophy at the University of
Birmingham on the cosmological argument
for God's existence I've had a deep
interest in Islamic philosophy and
theology I was able to resuscitate the
ancient cam cosmological argument uh
which is now once again at center stage
and as a result countless Muslims all
over the world are following reasonable
faith and are appreciative of the work
that we're doing so when I went on to
Germany to do my second doctorate in the
theology it was only natural that I
would choose Islam as my uh area of
specialization and it was during that
time that I worked through the entirety
of the qan and studied Islamic Theology
and history and as I read the Quran I
was
surprised by the evident
misunderstanding of the Christian
doctrine of the Trinity that I found
there for example in Surah
5116 Allah is portrayed as saying to
Jesus Jesus Son of Mary Did you ever say
to mankind worship me and my mother as
Gods besides God and Jesus replies I
could never have claimed such a thing uh
indeed such a caricature of the
Christian doctrine of the Trinity is uh
a Blasphemous monstrosity no wonder
Muhammad rejected it if that's what he
thought the Trinity taught but I think
that the basic doctrine of the Trinity
is actually taught in the pages of the
New Testament itself and it consists of
just two fundamental tenets first that
there is exactly one
God and second that there are three
persons who are properly called God
whereby properly I mean literally truly
as opposed to metaphorically or
hyperbolically so that's it no
metaphysical mumbo jumbo no theological
Hair S splitting this is a simple and
straightforward Doctrine God is an
immaterial tri-personal
being now standing opposed to the
doctrine of the Trinity is the Islamic
concept of God and the doctrine of Ted
or the Oneness or Unicity of God and
this is a Doctrine which is very
confusing and very controversial among
Islamic theologians there are a number
of different versions of Ted on which
there is no consensus for example the
most basic Doctrine would state that
there is exactly one God and that is a
point of
Dr Craig would you would you like to
continue your comments here just to
finish out your thought and then we'll
give extra time to oh you say I've used
up my time yes oh I'm sorry um yes I'll
just uh finish with the thought uh that
this is a very controversial Doctrine it
has a number of different versions and
so I'm interested in hearing what is the
version of Ted that uh Mr hijab espouses
uh and how would he justify that
that all right so Muhammad whenever
you're ready feel free to begin your
opening statement and you will get
another 15 seconds on
top I want to start off by saying thank
you very much to the organizers and to
Dr William Lane Craig for for this
discussion to dive straight into it the
last comment that Dr William Lane Craig
made is absolutely problematic uh it's
erroneous in fact the Muslims have never
had a problem discussing the Hess of God
they have had controver meres
surrounding the oness of God but that's
aside the point today we're talking
about the Trinity and it's quite
astounding that on a topic to do with
the Trinity that Dr Craig decided to
talk abouted which is not on the topic
today Dr Craig himself sorry to say does
not even represent mainstream
Christianity when it comes to the
Trinity he attacks Thomas aquinus and he
can correct me if I'm wrong for example
he corrects Thomas aquinus on the fact
that he believes in one self theories
and he says that for for example if you
take the is of identification for God
and you believe in that uh the father is
God and the son is God therefore it
follows that the father is the son this
is his view of Thomas aquinus he also
says that the Trinity is against Divine
Simplicity which Thomas aquinus and
other places actually does espouse
that's his View and he can correct me if
I'm wrong so that's I mean Thomas Aquin
is one of the Saints of Catholicism and
we're talking about a great deal of
people who follow that obviously 50% of
Christians are Catholics he doesn't just
take aim at aquinus he takes aim at the
the church fathers he church he T he
takes aim at the church fathers Gregory
of Nar Gregory of nanus Basil he clearly
states for example that they believe in
a kind of polytheism uh because if you
take the fact that the father is God the
son is God and the Holy Spirit is God in
a full sense that this is a kind of
polytheism so it's what what version of
of Christianity or of the Trinity is Dr
William Lane Craig representing he's
representing his own version ladies and
gentlemen he's not representing the
version of the majority of Catholics the
majority of Protestants the majority of
uh Eastern Orthodox and what he said
about the Quran as we've just mentioned
is erroneous he said that in chapter 5
verse
116 that the Quran depicts the trinity
in the wrong way the Quran doesn't even
mention the trinity in that verse and
you don't need to know Arabic language
to understand that because the Trinity
is not mentioned in chapter 5: 116 it
says that did you say that you take me
and my mom as Lords Gods beside
God means God's PE subjects of worship
we do believe like Protestants as he
claims he is that Mary is venerated to a
point of worship that doesn't mean that
she's part of a trinity so he's got a
misreading of that and in my next
segment I'm going to talk about how he
opposes practically all of Christianity
with the Eternal begotten son Doctrine
but I would like him to correct me if
I'm wrong in so much as I've represented
his views on one self theories and the
is of identification and uh his views
also uh on the church fathers and how he
he he openly aim takes aim at them uh
actually to be honest with you so I
think that's my
time all right let's turn it over to Dr
Craig you've got uh two minutes for your
first uh response among Christian
trinitarians there are two very broad
schools of thought called social
trinitarianism and Latin
trinitarianism now Thomas aquinus is a
representative of Latin trinitarianism
and Mr hijab is quite correct that I
reject aquinas's doctrine of Latin
trinitarianism because I don't think it
does Justice to the biblical data as I
say the biblical data teach that there
are exactly three persons Father Son and
Holy Spirit who are properly called God
and so those of us who are social
trinitarians uh take this very seriously
and literally that there are three
centers of
self-consciousness in God God is a an
immaterial tri-personal
being and my claim is that this is the
the doctrine that is taught in the New
Testament and as a Christian who
believes that uh Holy scripture is the
only inspired source and authoritative
source for uh Christian faith and
practice I believe what the New
Testament teaches uh about the doctrine
of the Trinity and I am less concerned
with Conformity to uh later
ecclesiastical developments of that
Doctrine so I'm taking my stand on what
I call the biblical doctrine of the
Trinity which I've already stated now I
do think that the Islamic doctrine of
Ted is very relevant here because this
is the doctrine that is opposed to the
Trinity namely that God is absolutely
one and yet this Doctrine comes in so
many different versions does God have
physical parts does God have
metaphysical parts are all of God's
properties identical to one another is
God distinct from his properties is
God's Essence the same as his existence
Muslim theologians cannot come to
consensus on this doctrine of the unity
or Oneness of
God so Muhammad you've got another 10
seconds 10 seconds did you say oh sorry
sorry I meant like a uh two minutes 10
seconds okay so uh Dr Craig has said
that he's uh he represents social
trinitarianism but he doesn't actually
represent all of social trinitarianism
for example he he takes aim as I've
mentioned at the church fathers who
represent a type of social
trinitarianism he States the following
given that there are three hypothesis in
God distinguished according to Gregory
in the in trinitarian relations then
there should be three Gods the most
pressing task of contemporary social
trinitarians is to find some more
convincing an answer to why on their
view there are not three Gods so in his
understanding William Lane Craig
believes that Gregory of Nissa who wrote
this book called not uh three Gods he
believes that this church father is a
polytheist this is a a social
trinitarian Doctrine will come to Dr
Craig's understanding of the Trinity as
parts of God and his mical understanding
however the the fact remains that he
doesn't represent social trinitarianism
he represents his own version of social
trinitarianism which quite frankly let's
let's demographically of 100% Christian
population I would even wage 1% follow
what he believes in so that's the first
thing the second thing is he he's
talking about the Quran he agrees with
the Quran because he he believes William
Langan Craig believes he does not
believe in the Eternal generation of the
sun which is something in the Nan Creed
he does not believe in the generation of
the sun because that would make the son
generated and caused and that is staple
Islamic reasoning the Quran says say he
Allah one and only Allah who the
eternally besought of all the
self-sufficient he begets not nor is he
begotten William L Craig believes the
Islamic standard over and above 1,500
years of Christian belief because no one
took his belief for 1,500 years of
Christianity no one took his belief that
the the son was not eternally begotten
and the Quran does say that because the
Quran indicates that being begotten is
an is an inhibition on the necessity and
Independence of God so he agrees with
the Quran and he rejects the
Christianity as as a whole Orthodox
Christianity all right Dr Craig turn it
back over to you another two minutes I
want to reiterate that what I am
defending is the biblical doctrine of
the Trinity that is found in the pages
of the New Testament itself
so of course it's a version of uh social
trinitarianism there are many varieties
and no one takes the writings of Gregory
of Nissa to be authoritative for
Christian doctrine it's just one opinion
among many and my critique of Gregory
was simply that he didn't do a very good
job in uh answering the questions about
uh the three persons in one uh being or
Essence so uh I again am going to be
defending a very simple version of the
doctrine of the Trinity that then can be
elaborated in a number of different
directions for example you can add to my
model the Eternal generation of the Son
and the procession of the spirit in the
forthcoming book on the Trinity you
referred to Cameron William hasker does
exactly that hasker and I see eye to eye
on our model of the Trinity except
hasker as this additional element of the
inter trinitarian processions and that's
fine the reason I don't espouse it is
because it's not found in the pages of
the New Testament itself I am basing my
doctrine of the Trinity on what the New
Testament teaches which is that there is
exactly one God and there are exactly
three persons who are properly called
God
what I'll do at this point is I'll just
go back and forth and I'll I'll say
something if I need to but otherwise
feel free to just go ahead and take up
your time
Mohamed is can hear us now yeah can you
hear us okay
yeah well feel free yeah feel free to go
ahead right now okay yeah so Dr William
laye Craig has not admitted Ed openly to
the audience that his view of the denial
of the Eternal begotten son which is the
second person of the Trinity is a view
that was not held by all of Christian
Christianity for sorry for can you hear
me yeah sorry it's a view that has not
been held in all of Christianity for 17
until the 17th century the first
recorded to my knowledge to my knowledge
the first person who denied the Eternal
begotten nature of the sun was Royal in
the 17th century so we're talking here
about a fringe opinion of a fringe of
opinion of a fringe opinion but what
seems to be interesting is William Lane
Craig was attacking the Quran in the
beginning in his in his first
introductory statement however he agrees
with the Quran because the Quran states
that being begotten is an inhibition is
a dimunition it's something it inhibits
and retracts from the detracts from the
fact that God is necessary God is
necessary God is independent God is
self-sufficient and William Lane Craig
admits this so he disagrees with
Protestant Christianity he disagrees
with Orthodox Eastern Orthodox
Christianity he disagrees with the
Catholic and he agrees with who he calls
Muhammad he agrees with the Quran on
this specific issue so this is the first
thing he has not admitted this yet why
does William Lane Craig not admit to the
audience that his view about the Eternal
begot son is commensurate with the
quranic discourse and is in commensurate
with his with Christianity as a whole he
in fact attacks Nan Creed he talks about
well Gregory of Nissa is not an
authority but the Nan Creed is an
authority according to Catholics and
according to easn Orthodox in fact they
consider it to be Dogma the Nan Creed
itself is that so he has to now admit to
the audience freely and openly yes you
say I believe what the Quran States is
more coherent than what Christianity
said for 17th centuries please say that
so Dr Craig when you're ready feel free
to uh respond um you've got two minutes
I I I would like to if we could go go to
discussing the uh logical coherence of
the Trinity it feels like we've been
discussing uh whether or not Dr Craig's
views are heretical or sort of unpopular
um yes which is not to say that they're
false I I'm claiming to be defending the
New Testament doctrine of the Trinity so
I'm not denying
uh Mr hijab the procession of the son
and spirit as I said you can add that to
my model if you want to but it's not
affirmed in the New Testament and the
earliest Church fathers didn't affirm
that Doctrine people like ignacius
Clement um and and others in the uh in
the post-apostolic age this Doctrine
originates in the so-called logos
christology of the Greek apologists like
athenagoras and Justin Martyr and and so
forth and I would follow them if that
Doctrine were to be found in the New
Testament but I think the majority of
Scholars would say this Doctrine is not
a new testament Doctrine and therefore
no Christian is obligated to believe it
unless he recognizes the conciliar
authority of these uh later credle
statements that you mentioned but as a
Protestant I bring even the Creeds
before the bar of scripture and weigh
them by their Conformity with scripture
now in terms of agreeing with what the
Quran says of course I agree with lots
that the Quran says I don't maintain
that the Quran is 100% false it has all
sorts of truths in it for example uh
that first uh tenant of the doctrine of
the Trinity there is exactly one God uh
Islam is a monotheism as is Judaism
Christianity so I agree with lots of
things in uh Islam but I do not agree
with Ted that uh God is this
undifferentiated Unity as opposed to
three persons in one being a a spiritual
immaterial tri-personal
substance all right and Muhammad when
you're ready okay so this is what Dr Dr
Craig says he says for although creedy
affirmed the doctrine of the generation
of the Son and the procession of the
spirit is a relic of gloos christology
which finds virtually no warrant in the
biblical text and introduces a
subordinationism into the godhead which
anyone who affirms the full deity of
Christ ought to find very troubling so
it's very clear here that Dr Craig has
understood what Nan christology is and
he's essentially saying you've got these
Greek philosophers who've corrupted
Christianity and introduce a
subordination into it and now this is
not something found in the New Testament
the the Eternal begotten nature of the
son I'm saying I agree with you Dr Craig
this is what I agree with you on but the
problem is this the problem is no one in
Christianity did agree with you until
her Hernandez role in the 17th century
so the point we're making is if the
biblical text was so clear for everyone
to see how could it be that for almost
2,000 years nobody could could detect
what you're talking about and all these
Church fathers from the ordinary
language of the text of the Bible
understood the Eternal begotten Doctrine
in a different way then the Bible then
is an encrypted text it's a text that
nobody can access for 17 years until
William Lan cray comes or roel comes or
somebody else comes and tells us what
it's meant to be this is preposterous
this is another problem you're adding
layers of problems to Christianity
you're adding layers of issues and
complications for Christianity now you
were talking about what we're not
talking about the coherence of the
Trinity this is at the heart of the
coherence of the Trinity because most
trinitarian models as you know has
inside of it or embedded into it this
idea that the sun is eternally begotten
you consider that to be a subordination
position what I'm saying to you is if
it's a subordination is position then
the Trinity is incoherent on many
different grounds for example when we
talked about aquinus I agree with your
assessment of aquinus that it's if you
take the is of identification that the
father is God and the son is God
therefore the father is the son The
Logical law of uh identification the law
of identification would be contravened
so I agree with you this is is at the
heart of the coherence of the Trinity so
you'd have to say well maybe half of the
Christians of the world are believing in
an incoherent trinitarian Doctrine no
problem me me and you both agree we have
to acknowledge that not all Christians
believe in the model of William Lane
Craig in fact I think seldomly anyone
does so this is the reason why I've
mentioned at this point but we will go
to the heart of Dr William Lane Craig's
model of the trinity in what will follow
cuz I do have my arguments against that
and I will present them uh to Dr Craig
and I I I'm pretty sure he will not be
able to answer them in any coherent
fashion and he has not done any service
to Christianity this is not Christian
apologetics this is Christian
capitulation he's capitulated to the
Muslim arguments we've gone uh almost 50
seconds over so we'll go 2 minutes 50
seconds for Dr Craig and his response
okay well I'm not capitulating to anyone
Mr hijab I am defending the doctrine of
the Trinity that is taught in the New
Testament and I am under no obligation
to defend later doctrines taught in the
uh 13th century by Thomas aquinus or
others I did mention the names of
certain Church fathers that held to the
New Testament Doctrine uh Clement of
Alexandria Clement of Rome uh ignacius
for example so it's simply not true that
um From the Beginning Christian
theologians have affirmed these inter
trinitarian processions this arises
somewhat later in the logos christology
of the Greek apologist to repeat myself
now you have exactly the same sort of
doctrinal evolution within Islam you
yourself know that as a Sunni you
disagree
with um Muslims belonging to other
schools with respect to doctrines like
Ted or the uncreated of the Quran is the
Quran a created product or is it
something that is co-eternal
uncreated and necessary alongside God uh
these are doctrines that develop later
in Islam uh and you are free to affirm
or reject them and there's great
controver y among Islamic theologians on
these doctrines so the fact that uh
Christians take a wide variety of views
on the Trinity is
unremarkable it's insignificant so long
as the doctrine of the Trinity that is
found in the pages of the New Testament
is coherent and is taught there and I
now await your demonstration that this
is an incoherent Doctrine
all right Muhammad when you're
ready yeah so the difference between
Muslims and Christians in this regard is
that creedy and theologically Muslims
have disagreed on the Oneness of God
meaning how is God the way he is but
Muslims have never disagreed on the Hess
of God who is God in in the first place
how do we understand who God is is God
one three is it tritheism is it is it
sanism is it modalism these kinds of
issues have never Arisen in Islam
all Muslims the
the the the this ones that ones all of
the sh all of them agree that there's
one God so this is a a failure if you
want to compare the idea that you know
the father Son and the Holy Spirit and
the the Holy Spirit was only granted co-
equal co-eternal status in that full
sense somewhere in the fourth Century
there's no equivalent in Islam I don't
even think there's much equivalent in
many other religions this is the first
point now I'm you you you said you
awaited my you're awaiting my
demonstration you don't need to await my
demonstration you have people like Scott
Williams who have already demonstrated
this that you you believe that there are
three Wills of the Trinity you believe
that the father has a will which is
distinct from the Son and you believe
that the son has a will which is
distinct from the Holy Spirit and they
all have Wills that are distin from each
other my question to you is just one for
now how do you establish and this is the
question of Scott Williams in the in the
peer reviewed academic paper how do you
establish necess Neary agreement such
that those three persons of the Trinity
can never disagree this is my first
question to to get the ball
rolling e
okay you've just said it's perfectly
reasonable but you've offered absolutely
zero justification
why so here's my question if it's
necessary agreement that is to say and
you know this you've written books on
the calam cosmological arguments you
know the modal distinctions okay if it's
necessary agreement that means it's
impossible for them not to disagree and
for you to say it's impossible well as
you know there's logical impossibility
and there's metaphysical impossibility
my question to you is how do you
establish the impossibility of
disagreement this is the question of
Scott Williams it's not just my question
it's the question that you've been posed
in academic papers Richard swinburn
trying to answer this question uh
swinburn sorry I forgot his first name
now but swinburn tried to answer this
question and he said that it's got to do
with the relationships between the
father and the son yes and that the
father has a love relationship with the
son and obedience relationship these are
the lengths that theologians of the the
highest Eminence and of the top caliber
in Christianity have to to reach to try
and ex explain through the three- will
model which is a heresy once again
because you've adopted many heretical
positions it's a heresy let's be honest
and say this three- will model that you
now have to explain why there is
necessary agreement so you have yet to
demonstrate to the public how is it
impossible for them to disagree this is
my
question
e e
okay so the the said Divine Perfection
this is the key term that you've used
but in other context you've in other
context you've accepted that God there
has to be a level of arbitrariness in
God's decision making otherwise it would
lead to necessitarianism and modal
collapse so if it was one Divine
Perfection that was that exists in
within each of the wills that would mean
to say that all of them really don't
have a choice in the matter in which
case God doesn't have will that's the
first argument the second argument is
the following you've made this comparon
with
god with cbus the the the the
three-headed dog and this is I mean if
you if you can see on the camera this is
exactly what you've written in your
article that God is like a three-headed
dog you got one two three okay and just
as it's one body and three heads you
know the Trinity is the same thing it's
one body and three different heads
that's what you've said now my my
question to you is as follows if you
have sies twins and this you've been
asked this once again before by Snider
on reviewed journals if you have a
conjoint twin what person a person B
would you consider that to be one person
or would you consider that to be two
people this is my question all right um
I certainly think that God has
contingent properties and that what God
Wills he Wills
contingently uh in many cases for
example the will to create the world is
a free decision by God which is freely
willed
so I'm not maintaining at all that
everything about God is necessary and
that he does nothing contingently my
claim is simply that given this peric
cortic interpenetration of the persons
of the Trinity they always act uh in
harmony with one another now the example
I used of kerberus uh Mr hijab I think
has been greatly misunderstood that is
not intended to be an analog ology to
the Trinity that was meant to be a
springboard for thinking about what it
means to be three persons in one being
and so I uh thought of this mythical dog
in the uh labors of Hercules guarding
the gates of Hades which has uh three
heads so presumably three brains so
three states of consciousness of what
it's like to be a dog and then based on
that I endowed them with
self-consciousness and personhood
and uh my position would be that you
have uh in that case three persons in
one being and it would be similar with
the Siamese twins or triplets you have
three brains three centers of
self-consciousness and so three persons
now in the case of God he doesn't have a
physical body so what I argue there is
that God is an immaterial spiritual sub
substance or
Soul who is so richly endowed with
cognitive faculties that he has three
sets of cognitive faculties each
sufficient for personhood and therefore
there are in God three centers of
self-consciousness and that would be a
model of what it is to talk of God as an
immaterial Tri personal
being you you say that
yeah you you say you say that this is
not an analogy but that's exactly what
you write in your article you say
perhaps we can get we can get a start at
this question by means of an analogy Mr
hijab that's a springboard to thinking
about drra let's let's let's let
Muhammad finish his his thought I
understand but you you you you denied in
your you denied in your response there
that this was an analogy and you've
written in your written work that this
is perhaps we can get uh can get a start
at this question by means of an analogy
and then you mention curus as the the
analogy so the point is this I know it's
difficult I know it's very embarrassing
I'm sorry to say I mean comparing God to
a dog anyway I mean we wouldn't compare
a prophet to a God but let's just for
the sake of argument we're analogizing
god with the with the dog now I asked
you a question which is that if you have
a conjoined twin sii's twins one of them
commits murder we're going to put both
of them in prison one of them does
something this dog here can slick this
dog this here can bite this dog these
are three different centers of
consciousness why are we considering
this to be one dog only because it has
overlapping bodies this is a question
that was posed to you in the academic
literature we've heard your response I
have to say it's a very insufficient and
unsatisfactory response absolutely
unsatisfactory this is your model of the
Trinity I think this could be debunked
by children with all due respect this is
your model of the Trinity now going to
the part of you have to now maintain
that God is made out of parts and you've
said this you've made clearly you have
the view that God is part uh uh they are
parts of God no problem my question to
you is this who created the universe did
the father create the universe did the
son create the universe or did the Holy
Spirit create the universe who is
responsible for the creation of the
universe now on your model you cannot
actually say that the father created the
universe in a full sense if you do say
that then you can't say that the son
created the universe in a full sense and
if you you say that you can't say the
holy spirit because you can't have two
subjects operating on one object and
creating it and being responsible for it
in a full sense I can't go to the gym
and pump 100 kgs by myself as well as my
friend over here or William Lan Craig
doing the same
thing it could be shared but then if
it's shared then you've got one third
God so can you clarify do you believe
that the father is onethird responsible
for the creation of the universe or do
you believe in The Logical contradiction
that you have two two subjects that are
fully responsible for the creation of
the universe which one you believe I
gave you an extra 20 seconds for the uh
Interruption but Dr Craig it's now your
turn two minutes causal
overdetermination is not incoherent Mr
hijab imagine a candle being lit by two
simultaneous matches Each of which is
sufficient to um illuminate the candle
in the case of the Trinity the classical
Christian doctrine is in Latin Opera add
extra Sun indivisa that the operations
of the Trinity toward the external uh
world are undivided and therefore
undertaken by all three persons at once
now I don't agree with that Doctrine in
every case I I think that leads to real
problems but I think that is very
plausible with respect to the doctrine
of creation that the three persons act
uh in concert with each other to create
the world um so they're all responsible
for the creation and in the New
Testament creation is ascribed both to
the father uh and to the
son if they're responsible they can only
be responsible either in a partial sense
or in a full sense they can't be
responsible both in a part in in a
partial sense and a full sense you said
co uh causal overdetermination I'm sorry
to say you have not answered the
question the question is can you have
two subjects that are fully fully
responsible one to a degree of a 100%
fully responsible for the creation of
one thing in its entirety for example
can you have two mothers that are fully
responsible fully responsible for the
production of one child fully
responsible I think even the transgender
movement would raise their eyebrow to
this the LGBT they will say no Dr Craig
has lost it to say no one could say this
can there be two authors that are fully
responsible for the writing of one book
can there I mean once again when you
when you talk about you don't want to
say this because I know it's it's heresy
it's a heresy to say that the father is
not the creator of the universe 100% but
that's what you have to say to avoid
contradiction so why don't you say that
why don't you say that the father is not
the Creator he is a partial Creator he
is a one-third Creator he's a 33%
Creator the father is not fully
responsible for the creation of the
universe is that correct I I don't think
you understand causal overdetermination
Mr hijab when two matches light a flame
simultaneously or light a candle they
don't each contribute 50% to the
lighting of the candle they are each
100% sufficient for the effect but they
act concurrently with each other uh and
so in the Act of Creation I see
absolutely no problem with saying that
there is a concurrence here of the
action of the three persons of the
Trinity to produce this creative
effect okay so to respond to this very
clearly your candle example with
overdetermination causal
overdetermination it's complete it's
this analogous to what we are talking
about why if you have two candles that
come together to light a flame you will
have a bigger flame you see it's there
sufficient condition yeah all there
sufficient you've written this in your
book on logic you have a fantastic book
and I recommend it to the people for
children on Logic the difference between
necessary and sufficient conditions what
is required for the lighting of a candle
what is a necessary condition for the
lighting of a candle is not achieved
with the lighting of two candles what is
required for the creation of the
universe is not achieved with the
creation W with two creators creating
the same universe so I'm saying it's
this analogous because we're talking
about the flame and the flame here is a
product of the two lights that you've
talked about which is a bigger flame I'm
saying now now each atom each uh Quark
each whatever it is in the universe uh
proton electron how is it conceivable
possible intelligible that there can be
two subjects that are fully responsible
for each of those things to a degree of
100% how is it possible that I can go to
the gym and pump 100 kilos and somebody
else can pump the same 100 kilos how is
it possible that a mother can give birth
to a child to a degree of 100%
and that another and that another mother
is responsible for the same to the same
degree for the production of the same
child this is these analogies are the
ones that
analogist not to cut you off um but we
couldn't hear you the last uh 10 seconds
or so can you just repeat your last
point I I I I I said the analogies which
are analogist are for example how is it
possible I asked for there to be a
mother who gives birth to a child and
that she is responsible for that
production 100% And there to be another
mother for 100%
responsibility why don't you admit that
on your model you have to say the father
is not fully holy completely responsible
for the creation of the universe he has
to only be partially responsible why
can't you admit that I I don't admit it
because your analogies are inept like
two women giving birth to the same child
in a case like that you're absolutely
right you cannot have over lapping uh
causes or causal
overdetermination but that doesn't imply
that there are not other cases such as
the illustration I use to show that
there can be cases of causal
overdetermination where three agents
work together to bring about a single
effect now every physical illustration
is going to involve points of disanalogy
when you're talking about spiritual
entities so the fact that maybe the
flame would be bigger if it's lit by two
matches instead of one match that's just
irrelevant to the question of whether or
not you can have uh two causes uh
currently acting to produce a single
effect so I'm I'm just not persuaded At
All by your
objection it's it's it's not it's with
with the greatest of respect but it's
not for me to be I mean it's not for you
to be persuaded with what I'm saying is
really for us to be persuaded of what
you're saying because frankly even
Christian co-religionists of yours don't
are not accepting what you're saying
Scott Williams who wrote a peer-reviewed
paper and he was he was asking the
fundamental question about necessary
agreement and he gave a an example which
maybe we can move to because I don't
agree with anything you've just said
there I mean you talked about the flame
the the two the two matches coming to to
create a bigger flame but that is
clearly a different product the two
matches are different to the flame there
is not a single analogy that you can
bring which match the analogies that
I've brought forward which which show
the fundamental point which by the way
many of the Islamic uh thinkers and like
IB rush andazi and others spoke about
this at length which is that you cannot
have two subjects that are responsible
fully for the same thing to a degree of
100% but the public will judge the
public will judge what who is right and
who is wrong on this and maybe even your
Christian Brethren will judge but at
this point you have not convinced
anybody the second point that you
mentioned yes
he's got another
minute oh oh sorry yes so the point my
question is this now unnecessary
agreement yes if the father wanted to do
something let's say for example he
wanted to to take life away from William
Lane Craig and the son wanted to keep
life in William Lane Craig is it
possible that that can both happen at
the same time no it cannot happen is it
possible that both of them won't happen
no cuz that will Contra contradict the
law of excluded middle the first one
contradicts law of non-contradiction the
second one contradicts the law of
excluded middle is it possible that
William Lane Craig can have life in his
body without any reason no because that
contradicts the PSR the principle of
sufficient reason now the question is
this is it is the father capable of
supervening on the will of the son is
the son capable of supervening on the
will of the father is the father capable
of creating the universe all by himself
all right that's time without any
involvement from the Sun
oh those are two different questions
certainly the father would be capable of
creating the universe by himself if he
wanted to and the son wanted to what I'm
arguing simply is that there is no
disagreement among the three persons of
the Trinity nor is there any reason to
think that this is impossible or
incoherent and in fact the position that
I'm articulating here is the standard
chrisan position oper extra indiva the
operations of the Trinity toward the
external world are undivided uh it's
only the Opera ad intra the intra
trinitarian relations that are
traditionally
differentiated uh from each other so the
position I'm taking whether it's right
or wrong is the mainstream uh Christian
view it's not a peculiar ity of William
Lane Craig's
theology no no no the position that You'
sorry sorry the position that you take
on partialism is absolutely not the
mainstream view I mean it's seen as a
heresy almost across the board it's seen
as a heresy across the board with
Protestants and Catholics and E Orthodox
to say that the the persons are parts of
God in the way that you've you've said
but put that to the side no problem my
my point is this let's go back to the
the thing that you've said you said it's
it's possible for the the father is
capable of creating the universe by
himself okay let's let's take that for a
second if the father is capable of
creating the universe by himself but he
does not create it by himself but
according to you creates it in concert
with the Son and the Holy Spirit these
are your words not mine in concert these
are the words you used yes that the
father is capable but no he does it in
concert with the will of the the the
Holy Spirit the Son and the Holy Spirit
that means to say that the the addition
of the Son and the Holy Spirit have had
an inhibiting impact on the will of the
father that means to say that the father
is being inhibited by the son and by the
way just to be clear this is not my
arguments this is exactly the argument
of the
Quran in chapter 23 verse number 91 that
Allah has not taken a son nor does he
have any creator with him if that was
the case they would have taken each part
of what they have created and they would
have tried to outstrip one another in
power the reason why you are not able to
answer this question is because it comes
from the highest Source we believe it
comes from God this argument is a Godly
argument and this is why necessary
agreement on your model cannot there is
no real way to prove it you ask what is
incoherent about your model what is
incoherent about your model is that when
you look at it and you look at each
person of the Trinity and you look at
the father what he's capable of doing by
himself versus what he's capable of
doing the Son and the Holy Spirit you
realize that that he's capable of doing
less because of the Son and the Holy
Spirit and if he's capable of doing less
because of the Son and the Holy Spirit
that means to say that the Son and the
Holy Spirit are having an inhibiting
impact which is is not all powerful then
the father has been stripped from his
omnipotence because of the Son and the
Holy Spirit there's no possible way that
you can have a part of God which is both
omnipotent in the full sense and in the
partial sense at the same time because a
part is by definition smaller than the
whole wouldn't you agree with that
that the part is not the whole certainly
yes but I I I simply don't understand
the objection that you are pressing here
I I don't see how the Father the Son and
the Holy Spirit willing together to
produce the same effect is any
imposition upon the father's will or
derides in any way from his omnipotence
I I think that your argument is just a
non sequitor and as far as partialism is
concerned I think our audience uh needs
to have this defined I suggested that we
could think of the persons as parts of
the trinity in the sense that the whole
godhead is not just one person now you
yourself hold to a sort of doctrine of
Ted that involves partialism if I'm not
mistaken because you believe that God
has a diversity of attributes like
omnipotence uh
omnipresence um goodness eternity and
that God is not identical to his
properties neither are the properties
identical to one another but that they
are uh distinct and so this is the same
sort of um position that I've suggested
that a trinitarian could take if he
wants to when Craig whether I believe in
the moon is made of cheese or whether I
believe that I can fly it doesn't change
the Trinity it won't make it into
coherent because right now we're talking
about whether the Trinity is coherent
and you're talking about what I believe
you're talking about fallacies and nonse
this is a to fallacy if if if anything
let's look at what you said because you
talk about the part of the God cuz you
do like to do this you like to make
analogies with animals Godly analogies
with animals you said a cat DNA or
skeleton is
feline even if neither a cat nor is just
sorry uh even if Nei is a cat nor is
this sort of downgraded or atten
attentuated felinity a scat skeleton is
fully and Ambiguously feline so what
you're doing is essentially saying that
the persons of the Trinity are to God
like a skeleton of a cat is like to a
cat and that is different from what
anything any Muslim has ever said in the
history of Islam not you will not find a
quote like this from a single Muslim
scholar even the most extreme of them or
the most heretical from a mainstream
demographic perspective but the the
point I'm making to you is this if it is
the case that God or the father is a
part of God if the son is a part of God
and if the holy spirit is a part of God
how can a part of an entity take
responsibility for the actions of the
whole entity the creation of the
universe is one act How can a of an
entity take full responsibility for the
creation of an entire act can you please
answer that question well real quick uh
we are coming at the end of our time
together today so we will need to
transition at this point to closing
statements okay okay no problem I think
the point made thank you so with that Dr
Craig whenever you're ready sure I I
want to close by addressing uh
personally our Muslim listeners today I
am imagine that most of you have
probably been raised in Muslim homes and
perhaps even in a Muslim culture and I
think you would agree that being raised
in a certain way doesn't provide a good
reason for thinking that that religion
is true if a Christian were to say that
I believe Christianity is true because
that's how I was raised you would think
that was a pretty weak argument in
exactly the same way I think many
Muslims today are beginning to ask
themselves how do I really know that
Islam is true um and as a result many
Muslims are succumbing to The
Temptations of the new atheism and to
agnosticism now I think that's wholly
unnecessary and unwarranted I think
there are good Arguments for the
existence of God and so I believe that
we should be theists but the question of
where you go beyond that to what sort of
theism Islamic or Christian theism I
think is going to depend upon the person
of Jesus of Nazareth who was Jesus of
Nazareth he was more I believe than just
a mere prophet of God he claimed to be
the long- awaited Messiah the Son of God
in a unique sense and the Divine human
son of man and he was crucified for
these allegedly Blasphemous claims but I
believe that there is good historical
evidence that God raised Jesus from the
dead and by doing that he Vindicated in
a public and unequivocal sense the truth
of those allegedly Blasphemous claims
for which he was crucified and for that
reason I am a convinced and Ardent
Christian theist and so I would simply
want to invite you to begin to look at
the person of Jesus and the evidence uh
for him and his resurrection we have
thousands of resources available free of
charge on our website
reasonablefaith.org and I would invite
you to view or to read those um
resources and to ask yourself could this
really be true um could the Christian
God actually be the true God and I think
if you'll do that um it could change
your life in the same way that it
changed
mine all right and Muhammad when you're
ready I did want to just mention really
quickly that I'm so sorry we haven't
been able to read any super chats we
just haven't had time today we wanted to
devote most of it to the dialogue
between Dr Craig and Muhammad so uh
Muhammad whenever you're
ready the public will realize that Dr
William Lane Craig despite completing
two phds and in my opinion being the
foremost and the most prolific and most
influential most significant Christian
debat of the last century has retreated
from the entire discussion allog
together instead of talking about the
Trinity and summarizing his arguments
which he knows are feeble and that the
Christian population doesn't even agree
with themselves he started talking about
the resurrection and crucifixion of
Jesus Christ and he's gone into full
preacher mode instead of going into
philosophical mode and rational mode
which he was he made his career on
that's the first thing look I mean at
the end of the day the public will see
and the public will make their decision
today based on what we have said because
what we have done is we've dismantled
Thomas ofus together me and Dr William
Lan Craig
yes Dr William Lane Craig is right that
the ident if you take an identity few of
God such that the father is with the
identity is God and the son is God and
the Holy Spirit is God in that sense
then that means that the father is the
son because that contv the law of
identity to say that it's not the case
and if you take the social trinitarian
view of Gregory of Nissa and these other
people which many of the Eastern
Orthodox believe that's already 60 or
70% of Christianity then according to
him is polytheism so me and Dr Craig
Dand work together to dismantle the
majority of the Christian faith and then
now we we talked about his view which is
the partial view really and truly and
we've seen how it doesn't achieve
necessary agreement we've achieve we've
seen through the quranic arguments how
the that the wills cannot they don't
always have to uh there's not an
impossibility for them to conflict and
what I will say is this he talks about
reasonable Faith I've been following
reasonable faith and that they've done
really good work with the atheist but
the saans Institute which also has which
I work for co-
has a website which is sapiens
institute.org has a lot of what you what
he talk about Christianity for Islam so
if you're a Christian listening to this
and you realize now that the Trinity is
false it's defunct it's a rationally
incoherent Doctrine and you want the
pure monotheism the one God to worship
without this complication this father
son Holy Spirit Incarnation this that
the other then it's Islam that you have
to start looking into with with
sincerity if you are sincere if you are
sincere the whole problem is solved
the whole problem is solved sapiens
institute.org and if you want evidences
for the rationality and the truthful
Islam then muhammadh hijab.com has a an
article of 10 of the evidences of why
Islam is true so the point I'm making to
you is that the the argument has been
failed miserably by Dr Craig he has not
been able to achieve even to the even to
the pleasure or the satisfaction of his
co- religionist a standard of evidence
that is acceptable uh for a rational
mind
all right thank you do you mind if we if
I ask you guys one one last question Dr
Craig I know you've uh you've got a
short time limit here but can I ask one
question that might help to to bring us
back together so I sent you guys these
questions in advance but I want to know
what is one thing that you like about
the other person's views I kind of
encourage some more in I like his
monotheism we both agree that there is
exactly one God uh moreover I like his
denial of divine simplicity
uh I don't agree with those who say that
God um is not uh complex in his being
uh Mr hiab's doctrine of Ted which we
really didn't hear very much about
tonight um is not a doctrine of divine
Simplicity which says that God's
properties are all identical that God is
identical to his Properties or that his
Essence is existence and so on that uh
we very much KR and I appreciate um that
positive feature of his
view muhamad what about
you I like Dr William Lan Craig as a
person I think he's done a fantastic job
and I and I've read almost every single
book that he's written uh it's maybe to
his surprise um but what I will say is
uh this I mean what I do like about his
views is his bravery in denying the
begotten uh the Eternal begotten naturee
of the second person yes on the one hand
he's rejected all of Christianity
Orthodox Christianity with a with a
small case o he's rejected it but it
takes bravery to do so I have to say
intellectual and academic bravery to do
so and I particularly like it because I
agree with it how can you believe that
there is a co-equal co-eternal
son who has now been generated and
caused by the father this is a
contradiction and it's rationally
implausible in my opinion and it's
something we are taught as children as
5-year-olds and
six-year-olds say is Allah one and only
Allah the self-sufficient he begets
not he begets not nor is he
begotten and there's nothing like him
and this is the simple doctrine of what
it means the Islamic standard of
believing and worshiping one God that if
someone believes in they will be saved
they will be
saved well I appreciate you guys
watching capturing Christianity this
debate um feel free to uh continue
watching our other content and subscribe
and uh if you'd like to support us
patreon.com again again links to that
are in the description thank you guys
for uh watching today we'll see you in
the next video